hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar
titled starting at the source tissue
extracellular vesicles and alzheimer's
disease
this webinar is part of the cell biology
virtual event and i am susie valdez
of lab roots and i will be your
moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by
labyrinths so let's get started before
we begin i want to remind everyone that
this event
is interactive and we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want
during the presentation to do so simply
type them into the ask a question box
and click send we'll answer as many
questions as we have time for at the end
of the presentation
if you have any trouble seeing or
hearing this presentation just click on
that ask a question box located on the
top
left hand corner of your screen as a
reminder this presentation is
educational and offers free continuing
education
credits click on the continuing
education credits tab
located on the top right hand corner of
your presentation window
and follow the process to obtain those
credits i now present today's speaker dr
kenneth whitmer
associate professor of the molecular and
comparative pathobiology
at john hopkins university school of
medicine
for a complete biography of all of our
speakers please visit the biography tab
at the top of the screen dr whitwork
welcome
you may now begin your presentation sir
well thank you very much susie for that
introduction it's a pleasure to be here
today um and to
address all of you i understand that
there have been some talks
in the track on extracellular vesicles
today
and i will be talking with you about
extracellular vesicles that come from
tissue and specifically i'll be speaking
about
alzheimer's disease studies that my
group has done recently
so as susie mentioned i'm at the johns
hopkins university school of medicine
and i'm in the department of molecular
and comparative pathobiology i also have
an appointment
in neurology and also in our newly
newly founded richmond family center for
precision medicine
in alzheimer's disease i'd like to just
start by acknowledging my funding
and making my disclosures so a few
pictures of my lab here
and then the funding that we have from
the nih and from other sources
and in red i'm designating those sources
that have to do something with
alzheimer's disease
i'd also like to thank um my lab members
and also some of our contributors
so much of the work that i'll be showing
you today comes from postdocs in my lab
iao huang
and tom tridonks uh we also have some
excellent collaborators at johns hopkins
as well as collaborators from around the
world and so some of the work that we
are presenting today has also come from
australia
so from the labs of andrew hill um
leslie chang and laura vella
and so um i i want to today
talk about alzheimer's disease and evs
but i've also been asked to talk a
little bit about
efforts that have been made in the field
to ensure that we're pursuing our
studies with rigor and reproducibility
a little bit of background on myself and
the group that i come from
i'm in a group of about nine pis that we
call the the retrovirus laboratory
and we study enveloped viruses and
animal models
of hiv disease but recently of course
we've been getting into some other
envelope viruses including sars kobe 2.
so we call ourselves the retrovirus
laboratory and that's not because nobody
else at hopkins studies retroviruses
but rather because our group was the
first to study them
at johns hopkins and specifically back
in the 1970s
some of my colleagues were studying
animal models
they were studying lentiviruses that
infect sheep and goats
and when hiv came on the scene in the
early 1980s
um it became clear that hiv was related
to some of these lentiviruses
so i show you here an illustration from
a science paper that my
my former advisor published with bob
gallo and some others back in 1985.
these are electron micrographs and they
show you very clearly
that hiv and visnovirus which is this
virus that affects
sheep have similar budding processes so
their biogenesis is similar
and then their morphology is also quite
similar so you can see that electron
dense shell
you can see that there's an electron
dense core that forms
after release from the cell and i'm
going to be telling you a little bit
more about evs today too extracellular
vesicles
um and in fact an enveloped virus is
really just
a host ev that has been hijacked by a
foreign genomic program
well one of the early manifestations of
hiv disease aids
was a frank dementia um this is a paper
that also came out in the
mid 1980s showing that uh that patients
of
of hiv those who were infected with hiv
very rapidly had hiv proteins in
in brain and in fact aids encephalopathy
or hiv dementia
was a hallmark of aids especially in the
early days
of the epidemic so the the group that
i'm with
they developed an animal model of this
hiv-associated neurocognitive
disease and this animal model is the
pigtailed macaque of southeast asia
so just like a human being uh being
exposed to hiv
where we don't have an evolutionary
relationship with this virus it's only
been
in the population for decades or maybe
maybe a little over 100 years
um these pigtailed macaques and other
macaques of southeast asia
do not have their own lentivirus their
own simian immunodeficiency virus
this means that when we infect them with
with two well we actually use two
viruses so we use a swarm that
immunosuppresses
and we use a cloned virus that is
neurotropic
and this leads to development of that
neurologic disease
so when we infect those animals they
respond much as a human response to
untreated hiv infection and within three
months we have aids we have
decline of t cell counts and we also
have encephalitis in most of these
subjects
the encephalitis is then scored by
by two pathologists and we we uh we try
to understand what is causing
um this this this pathology in the brain
um now of course um since uh since hiv
was discovered
it only took a few years to develop the
first treatments
and by the late 1990s there were
combination treatments that were able to
suppress the replication of the virus
while also not allowing the virus to
mutate
around those those treatments and so
that very that very severe dementia the
encephalitis that was seen
early soon after hiv emerged
it has largely gone away now there are
still cases of course especially in
untreated individuals
but now there is a spectrum of disease
or different types of neurologic disease
that afflict the hiv positive
individuals
and we could see this hiv associated
neurocognitive disease
as a kind of neurodegenerative disease
and this has led us then also into
studies of other neurodegenerative
diseases including the one that i'll be
talking about today
alzheimer's disease we probably all know
somebody or
who has had alzheimer's disease and um
and
passed away with it or somebody who has
it today um
and unfortunately this is a disease that
has a massive burden on society on on
the on the caretakers
um on the individuals who are afflicted
with it and on everybody
so we could we could roughly divide
alzheimer's disease into two
categories the one is familial and this
is an early onset disease
and the other we call sporadic which
which comes with age
and there are factors that contribute to
familial disease
anti-sporadic disease
alzheimer's disease is also often
considered a proteinopathy that is to
say
a disease in which proteins are
misfolded
proteins are abnormally distributed
proteins form into into bodies or
tangles
that that interfere with the normal
functioning of the brain
and we can classify the disease into
stages
um under a few different regimens and
one of these um classifies
individuals from from a score of zero
which denotes normal cognition
all the way up to six where we've had
spreading pathology
throughout the neocortex and and so we
we find that we really need to have
biomarkers of disease
in most in most cases there's no
indication to go in and take a biopsy of
the brain so we don't really know
exactly what's happening there of course
imaging efforts are underway
but it would be quite convenient if we
could take a so-called liquid biopsy
maybe a sample of saliva perhaps a blood
plasma sample
and and and understand what is happening
in a particular tissue like the brain
so i'd just like to um to to make a
reference here to dimitrios capollanes
who is my colleague um
who is at the national institute on
aging in baltimore and is also
cross-appointed with
with johns hopkins and then one of his
collaborators ed goetzel
and they have a whole raft of papers on
using
l1 cam which is a receptor that can be
found
on neurons and then other cells as well
to obtain
extracellular vesicles in the periphery
that have putatively come from the brain
or at least from neurons
um and they've they've found many
markers uh protein markers
uh protein modifications that are
associated
with alzheimer's disease and with other
with other diseases
so i'm going to be talking more later
about
about what we're doing to try to extend
this work and
and much of this has also been done in
collaboration with demetrius
so the extracellular vesicle you may
have heard a little bit about
extracellular vesicles today
the evs um we define them as
particles that are naturally released
from the cell um they
they are delimited by this lipid bilayer
so a piece of the cell membrane of the a
cell membrane that they brought with
them
they cannot replicate on their own
because they have no functional nucleus
and they contain a lot of different
molecular cargos
the average ev might be around a
millionth or
several millions of the size of the cell
that it came from so this is rather a
small particle
we usually think of them as being in the
range of about 30 nanometers in diameter
all the way up to several hundred
nanometers in diameter in fact they can
even be larger
than that they can be up to tens of
microns in the case of some large
oncosomes that are released by
um by by uh like cancer cells
um and in fact there's even a debate
about whether a platelet is
actually an extracellular vesicle i
would say it is i think a lot of
platelet biologists would disagree they
would say that it's a cell
but it does fit this definition of not
being able to replicate on its own
and of having come from a parent cell
um and and so in a sense the platelet
and
perhaps even the red blood cell which
has lost its nucleus
is even an ev so the composition of
course is this phospholipid bilayer
but then also proteins and nucleic acids
and metabolites that are brought along
from the parent cell
i'm not going to dwell a lot on the
different types of extracellular
vesicles but there are many
um the two that you probably hear about
the most are the exosome coming from the
internal and
internal compartments of the cell uh
specifically from the endosome the
multivesicular body
and the ectosome or the microvesicle
that you can find budding from the
surface of the cell
but there are other ways that that
extracellular vesicles can be formed
why do we study them why do we study
them in neurodegenerative diseases
well there there are multiple reasons um
they are
a source of biomarkers so they protect
the cargo they protect their internal
cargo
with this phospholipid bilayer and
importantly they can be traced back to
the cell of origin so i mentioned
l1 cam or cd7 cd 171
from the work of demetrius cavallanes
and this makes them particularly useful
in the liquid biopsy because if we have
a marker of a cell of origin no matter
what that cell is a hepatocyte
a cell in the heart a neuron an
astrocyte any
any cell that has its own characteristic
surface uh
surface signature that surface signature
can be released on the evs and so we at
least have a chance to say
this vesicle came from this source and
that one came from that source
and that that's why we like to use them
or we like to develop them for the
liquid biopsy
now of course evs also have a biological
function so they can
signal they can signal in several ways
one of them would be by actually
transferring functional molecules such
as rna
which has been very wide studied and i'm
going to talk a little bit about rna
today
but they don't necessarily have to
transfer that cargo doesn't necessarily
have to be a fusing event
with a target cell to release the cargo
in fact i think that a lot of
extracellular vesicle
mediated interactions and biological
processes
come when that vesicle interacts with
the surface
of a recipient or a target cell and and
you know it's it's interesting to think
of the ev as a kind of signaling
platform so it's not just
one molecule like a cytokine that's
binding to a receptor
rather you have an array of molecules on
the surface of the eb
that can each interact with components
of the target cell
and achieve a kind of signaling that
would not be possible with just one
uh one molecule alone
now naturally all these biological
functions
lead us to hope that we can develop
extracellular vesicles as therapeutics
but in the in the midst of the
excitement about therapeutics and
biomarkers we also don't want to forget
some of the other functions of evs that
may not be considered so exciting but
are also extremely
biologically important one of those is
taking out the trash
so evs are are carriers of toxic
entities from the cell of origin
so how better to release something from
the cell something that's
large than to put it into a vesicle and
get rid of it
uh and so the um the the trash function
i think is very important
um in preventing but then also in the
progression of neurocognitive
neurodegenerative disorders um and then
finally i'll just say that that eb's can
also be a form of nutritive support so
trophic support so one cell can help
another cell by
by transferring some uh some molecules
that can be used as nutrition
um some some some molecular recycling
that occurs
in the in the uh central nervous system
there have been a lot of studies
of of evs and how they participate in
crosstalk between
the different um components of the
central nervous system so
um astrocytes which are the most
abundant cell in the brain
communicate with neurons and vice versa
on the oligodendrocytes
are also involved in this ev
communication
and then the macrophages and microglia
the microglia being the
so-called resident macrophages of the
brain they can be involved in
inflammatory processes and
anti-inflammatory processes through
the release and the uptake of
extracellular vesicles
um and so the the proteins that are
involved in some of the
neurodegenerative diseases that we know
about
um are often associated with
extracellular vesicles whether they're
inside the evs or
or on the surface of the eps i run a
weekly journal club on evs uh that has
gone worldwide during the covid
uh pandemic and today we heard from ed
campbell
from loyola university in chicago and he
was telling us about alpha synuclein
a protein that's implicated in
parkinson's disease and how
extracellular vesicles can
carry this protein and shuttle it
so i want to note though that most of
what we know about
about extracellular vesicles in the
central nervous system
comes from studies of cell culture so
perhaps we're co-culturing different
cells from the central nervous system
or it comes from samples that we've
obtained from patients such as blood
plasma
but you know i if if we think about
um the biogenesis of evs where any given
cell is releasing these particles at all
times
and also taking up particles at all
times and even uh displaying these
particles on on its surface
we realize that the the major role of
extracellular vesicles is probably local
so probably on the cell that releases
them or neighboring cells
and not necessarily on another organ
system somewhere else in a
in a in in the body so we could say
that extracellular vesicles are most
likely to act in tissue
um but how do we study tissue so there
are multiple
barriers to a good study of
extracellular vesicles and tissue
so where are the evs in tissue they
would be found in
the so-called interstitial space so the
interstitial space is composed of the
extracellular matrix
that's that's built released by cells
and then the interstitial fluids
are we able to obtain evs from this
interstitial space
yes we are but what are we going to see
we will see evs that come from many
different cells and many different cell
types
our challenge in studying evs and tissue
and especially if we wanted
if we want to take the eb's out of the
tissue um is in liberating those
those eb's while maintaining the cell
integrity so we do not want to disrupt
the cells
and create artificial particles that are
going to look like uvs
but were actually produced during our
processing of the tissue
so this shows us that there's an
importance of just dissociating the
tissue very gently
and then also characterizing the evs in
a way that lets us determine whether
we're studying artifacts or
actual evs that were released um in the
cells and so
uh when when my lab starts uh started to
work on on tissue evs and we looked at
some of the literature that had been
published
we were surprised to see that many of
the studies that had been published
previously
were taking tissue and grinding it up or
or mincing it very finely
so this would be a mechanical process a
physical mechanical process that is
actually disrupting the cells
and it doesn't allow us to necessarily
draw conclusions
about the about the extracellular
vesicles
the other thing that we noticed was that
although most of the
most of the studies would look for
markers of extracellular vesicles
they would not look for cellular markers
so
what would not be incorporated into an
extracellular vesicle well one thing
might be a nuclear component
right because the ev is coming from the
surface of the cell or from
an internal compartment but probably not
from the nucleus at least not in most
cases
so so-called negative markers of
extracellular vesicles
include things like golgi er and nuclear
markers and we found that for most
studies none of these
negative markers were even examined so
it was impossible to say
whether the extracellular vesicles were
released in in
a native way so to speak or had been
produced during the the
processing um this is important and i
think the
um the international community came
together around 2011 and 2012
um to form the international society for
extracellular vesicles and i would
i would uh i would recommend that
anybody who's is really interested in
studying evs
take a look at isev the international
society um and the efforts um and
opportunities that it provides
so in 2014 there was a first initiative
at kind of standardizing the field
that's standardizing at least the
reporting
that should be done when one is when one
is reporting um
a study of evs and so this uh this early
document was called the minimal
information for studies of ebs
and in 2018 isev
and its community released an update to
this uh to these uh standardization
initiatives it was called nice of 2018
because of the year of publication
and this was an effort that included
more than 400
scientists 382 of them became co-authors
of the final product
um and so i had the the the honor and
also the very large responsibility
of um of helping to co-coordinate this
with claudi
so this was um this was a document
that took us through really every uh
step of an eevee
study from obtaining the materials to
processing them to characterizing them
i'm only going to dwell on the
characterization here because that's
what's relevant
um to what we are trying to do with with
the brain evs
and what we what we want to do with um
to show
to show each other that we have an ev
preparation
is first of all to demonstrate the
presence of evs
and we can do this by showing
transmembrane proteins or membrane
associated proteins
but we don't want just membrane
fragments right we also want to have
some of that internal
internal cargo and so it's also good to
show a cytoplasmic protein
we don't just want to show the presence
of evs we also want to interrogate the
presence of
expected contaminants and so these could
be things like plasma proteins
if we're working with blood plasma it
could be something like the tam
horsefall protein or uromodulin if we're
working with
with urine and in the case of cell
culture
or or cell sources like tissue
we might look at some of these uh deep
tissue contaminants so these nuclear
markers or others
that we would expect to be depleted from
evs now there's no
there's no universal marker here each um
each study is going to find the best
markers for its own purposes
but we do give some recommendations of
what some of those might be
and in addition to you know showing
these typical markers that are
enriched in evs or depleted from evs we
also have recommendations on
quantitation so how to how to get
particle counts and also how to do
single particle characterization and i
will
mention two of the techniques that my
lab uses to do that
all right so getting back to the
brain-derived dvs
um when when we when we became
interested in doing this
um there was a paper that had had had
just come out from
from andrew hill's lab and larabella's
lab in australia
and what they did was a um a complex um
but very rigorous technique
to separate extracellular vesicles from
brain tissue
and they were even able to do this on
archived uh frozen tissues
so what they did was just to very gently
uh slice the brain so
slice the brain sample you have to
expose some surface
then digest it with collagenase so this
is to digest those connections between
the cells
release the cells and release the other
components
of the tissue and then they did several
centrifugation steps to separate debris
from the extracellular vesicles and
finally
they did a density gradient so those of
you who have done density gradients you
know that it
um that this is a very rigorous process
but it's also a very difficult process
and so
not not just anybody in the lab is able
to do that it requires some uh some
training
and some very careful hands so we asked
the question of whether we could
possibly take this protocol
and simplify it a little bit and even
automate it by using a size exclusion
chromatography step
in the place of the density gradients
and we were quite aware that we might
not get
you know quite the purity that we get
with with a density gradient
but we hope that we could at least
eliminate some of the contaminants
and have a reasonably pure population of
ebs
so so in collaboration with the lab that
first published this
we tried a side by side comparison and
down here on the lower right i just want
to draw your attention to this western
blot what i'm showing here
are three markers so calnexin which is
one of those deep cellular markers that
we do not expect to see in evs or at
least to be
depleted in evs and then cd63 and cd81
are two tetraspanins these are proteins
that are associated with or embedded in
the um the lipid bilayer of the ev
so you can see that those two ev markers
on the bottom there
um so on the left is the brain
homogenous and then also a collagenase
treated brain
but on the right you see the comparison
of the density gradient containing
protocol
with the size exclusion protocol and so
in both cases we have the enrichment
of the lipid bilayer markers but we also
have the depletion of the calnex and
markers
and so this uh this this method then we
publish this modification of the method
in the journal of extracellular vesicles
and
the kind of icing on the cake was that
this was the first paper that was
published
in uh jev right after the night the 2019
impact factor was announced
so it's i think that impact factor i'm
not i'm not a big fan of impact factors
but
just getting an impact factor for a
young journal is a is a big step
and i think is a testament to the hard
work that a lot of members of the
community put into building this journal
and it has published indeed many
different methods papers
and also position papers that that seek
to encourage
the best science possible in the field
so just to summarize here what we're
doing is a minimal
physical disruption a gentle enzymatic
digestion
and then we do careful characterization
with those depleted and enriched markers
so now we're going to go into human
samples
but we might also be interested in
animal models
and so we have a few other questions
that we wanted to address
one of them being what if you can do
perfusion right so it so during a
necropsy of an animal could you do
perfusion to limit tissue damage and
perhaps get a better
yield or purity of evs the other is the
postmortem interval
what are we able to do with um with
samples that have been sitting around
for a while so unfortunately with human
samples
um we we are rarely able to get them
um in in in a reasonable period of time
um so our first conclusion was that this
size exclusion chromatography method was
a substitute for
or or perhaps an um in addition to the
the the density gradient protocol that
had previously
been employed our second conclusion was
that perfusion if you can do it so if
you have a mouse model or a non-human
primate model
it's a great way to minimize
digestion that might occur in that brain
between the time that it's harvested
and the time that it can be processed
into evs and so i'm just showing you
here
three different variations of our method
on the top you see the perfused samples
and there's not a lot of background
debris there compared with the
non-perfused samples which are shown on
the bottom
so if you can do perfusion that's great
and it also
helps out with those d cellular markers
like gm 130
bip and calnexin it might not eliminate
them completely from the mouse brain but
it does
it does reduce them so we we do use
perfusion when we can
and then finally what about postmortem
intervals so unsurprisingly
um and this was done with non-human
primate
brain samples we were able to see that
that that the
the the debris that was visible in
electron microscopy was increasing
over the time of that postmortem
interval which was defined as in just
how long that brain was sitting at room
temperature
before we processed it um so the earlier
you can get the brain
the better but of course we recognize um
that human brain samples are not able to
be processed that quickly
so now we're applying the method so now
we're getting um
into the the proteins and the rnas
that can be harvested from the brain so
the the next
few slides are going to be from human
brain and this is just
normal normal human brain this is not um
not specific to any particular disease
so what we observed when we did our
proteomics was that
when we took different fractions of the
human brain so we took the brain
homogeneous
we took a tent what we call a 10k
fraction which is large ebs that are not
very well purified this is just
something that we centrifuged
and then we finally took the fraction
where we had applied that size exclusion
chromatography to get the most pure evs
that we could
um and when we when we went from one
compartment to the other
we were able to see that there was
enrichment and i don't know if you can
see these uh these different labels here
but in the um in whole membrane and
plasma membrane
regions and basically anything that's
involved in the secretory process
as you would expect for exosomes
and so these were enriched in the small
evs and that very
pure fraction that we were able to
generate at the end of our protocol so
this was a good validation
of what we were of what we were trying
to do
we also saw that there was compar other
compartment enrichments
and we were interested in particular in
the lower graph here so the cns
cell markers so what markers of neurons
of astrocytes of oligodendrocytes and of
microglia were we able to see
in the evs that we harvested from this
tissue
this is important because what we
ultimately want to do as i mentioned
toward the beginning of my talk
is to apply a liquid biopsy to obtain
some of these
evs and to
you know i think that there have been
several studies multiple studies that
have been published on neurons
there have been a few studies that have
been published on astrocytes but there
are not a lot of
other um well-validated markers that can
be used
to obtain uh cell-specific evs from a
peripheral sample and so this was one of
our
one of the things that we attempted to
do and so we did
we did identify several good markers
that we followed up
using single particle analysis and i'll
tell you more about that towards the end
of the talk
all right so after that initial study
that kind of validated our approach and
showed us that we were enriching the
expected components
now we went on to study alzheimer's
disease and compared
comparing these alzheimer's disease
brains with um
with with uh supposedly normal controls
so our study design incorporated some
non-ad samples
and then 23 alzheimer's disease samples
that had also been genotyped according
to their april lipoprotein
e so apolipoprotein e is one of the risk
factors for sporadic alzheimer's disease
and so there are several genotypes here
um there are several several um
alleles so there's there's the four the
number four allele the number three
allele and number two allele so the four
allele is the one
that confers the most risk uh for
development of
of sporadic alzheimer's disease so we
wanted to understand if there was a
difference
in the amount or the quality of the evs
that were released from brain
that had these different apoe genotypes
the first thing to look at was counts so
how many evs are actually
harvested are we able to recover from a
certain amount
of alzheimer's disease tissue so how do
we do this how do we count something
that is as small as
an extracellular vesicle where we see
that most evs
are in that range of around 40
nanometers in diameter
up to let's say 150 there's not like
there's any kind of a cutoff
the method that we used was nano flow
cytometry
so so is very much like cellular
cellular methods hence the cyto in
cytometry
you're passing your sample through a a
channel and hitting it with a laser
uh but this instrument that we used is
only for small particles
so that that passageway has been shrunk
down to a size that is
that is just big enough to accommodate
the extracellular vesicles and not
cells the reason for that is that you
want to reduce the background as
as much as possible so that you're able
to detect very low scatter or low
fluorescence events
and so the background is low the other
innovation of this
of this instrument is that the material
is passed very slowly
through that passageway so in contrast
with cellular
the regular cellular cytometry where you
actually want to get as many events as
possible
here you're actually trying to get that
material to go slowly so that you can
integrate more signal while it's in that
path of the laser so we're able to
measure particles down to probably about
50 or 40 nanometers
and so i show you some things that we
obtained with beads here with with some
standard beads
and then evs so we can we can get sizes
and we also can get counts um of our
populations
and so um interestingly we did not see
any difference
in the yield between the ad and the
control and i'll come back to the um
to the apoe genotype in just a moment um
we did observe however um that the uh
it depended on how we how we normalize
these these uh these counts so we could
normalize to the amount of tissue or we
could normalize to the to the number of
particles
um so over here on the right um you can
see that i have the
that 10k that relatively impure fraction
and comparing it with the ev fraction on
the right
the reason for that difference in the
particle yield
per microgram of protein is that the evs
have a lot less contaminating protein in
them
than that earlier fraction and so we
have a much higher particle count to
protein ratio
um but interestingly we did not see a
big difference i'm drawing your
attention to the graph on the right
in the different genotypes and in fact
if anything
although it was not significant there
were more evs that were harvested
from the apoe444 genotype than the
others
although as i say that was not
significant
now this is a little bit different from
some of the study uh some one study in
particular that's been published that
indicates that there
are are fewer particles that are
released
however i want to stress that this is a
study that uh that included only a a
small number
um of samples and um and
um and and we we also we're not using
exactly the same model i mean we're
using an uh
we're using actually human samples here
not an animal model
um so our overall proteomics results
from these
uh brain-derived evs that were we were
able to harvest
showed that the ev fraction the purified
evs were the best at separating
the ad samples from the control samples
overall
and what about individual proteins well
here we found as well
that if we looked at the the rather
impure fraction the early fraction the
10k fraction
and compared it with the ev fraction the
ev fraction had many more
significantly different proteins in it
and thus is the more diagnostically
[Music]
advantageous what were some of these
proteins we were happy to see
that some of the proteins that we found
to be different between the alzheimer's
group and the control group
had been reported before um including
tau
including the 1433 proteins um and
when we looked at the processes that
were involved
um we we also found that this the
findings were consistent with our
understanding of alzheimer's disease and
neurodegenerative disease
in in in general so some of these
processes would include
um cellular protections against
oxidative stress
um neurogenesis was one of the big ones
so of course the flip side to
neurogenesis would be
senescence um senescence uh of of of the
neurons
um we saw several signaling pathways
that were that were um that were
differentially regulated in the
alzheimer's disease brain
also glycometabolism which which we
found quite quite interesting and then
even interactions between cells so
this this of course is also is also
something that has to be considered
in any kind of a tissue ev study so if
there are differences in the
interactions between cells this means
that's
that cells may be more or less sticky
for those uh
for those particles that they release
and so the amount of ebs that we harvest
from a tissue
may differ depending upon the disease
status
and and make it a little bit more
difficult to interpret results
all right so the the last part that i
want to share with you here is the
different rna biotypes that we were able
to observe
now of course we have also have
individual rna level data
but i just want to focus here on the rna
biotypes
and tell you first of all that we didn't
see any big differences
in the distribution so in other words if
we were to take a whole category of rnas
like trnas
yrnas and i've listed them over on the
right because i'm sure that the the
the x-axis is not so easy to read
we looked at many different categories
of rnas
and just at the total reads that went
into each of these biotypes for the
different samples
and we didn't see any significant
differences between the brain
homogeneous so the total input material
and the 10k fraction which was like this
fairly
impure release 8 fraction
and actually we had a similar result for
the ev
fraction except for one interesting
finding and that was with the
mitochondrial rna so there's
mitochondrial rna
that was differentially um uh apparently
packaged into the evs
um in the ad fraction versus the non the
ad group versus the non-ad group
and specifically there were fewer of
these so um so so we're
um this is this is a finding that we're
following up on and hoping to uh to make
some interesting
just discoveries here about about
metabolism especially
okay so what about looking at the
the biotypes and how they were
incorporated into the eb fraction so in
other words not not looking necessarily
at the disease
but rather at the different fraction um
and here
here we we found that uh that you know
you know not unexpectedly nuclear rna
or the mitochondrial rna um were much
less abundant in the evs than in the
parent tissue
um and and again i think this speaks to
the relative purity of our ebb
populations but there were a couple of
very
uh very surprising findings one of them
was on
micrornas so micrornas are probably the
most studied
rna type in extracellular vesicles and
there's a there are a couple very good
reasons for that one is that they're
important biologically
but another is that they're just very um
they're very small so easy to be
packaged
and they're very stable so so micrornas
were
among the first rnas to be found in evs
and and they've been they've been
i'm sure studied much more than any
other rna type
but what we found is that relative to
the total rna there was actually less
microrna
in the evs than in the parent tissue um
and even then
in the the more pure releasing fractions
um so so my rnas i think are
extremely important they can be they can
be excellent biomarkers they have a
function
but this finding i think is also
consistent with other findings that
we've made
that indicates that micrornas are not
the only molecules we want to look at in
ebs
and in fact there might be other rnas
that are much more informative in a in a
um in a biomarker setting one of those
is the protein coding rnas so mrnas
what we find is that there's actually
more
more protein-coding rna per per
nucleotide of rna in the ev than in the
parent cell and this was very surprising
to us
but i think it's consistent with these
rnas being
fragments so what we're looking at here
really is a degradome so the the rna in
the cell that has been broken down
and released into ev so this might be
part of that trash disposal mechanism
getting rid of messenger rnas that are
no longer intact
now now this might not be something that
is very functional in terms of what the
eb can do when it goes to a recipient
cell
but it's very exciting for me as
somebody who's looking for biomarkers
because the diversity the information
in the protein coding fraction is much
greater than what we would find in the
microrna fraction
um so this is um this is i think uh
uh another wake-up call to me and to
hopefully others in the field that we
should we should be looking across
rna biotypes and not just micrornas now
for the micrornas themselves
we did find micrornas that were
differentially regulated across the
disease
disease versus control and especially
some of the ones in the
mir 132 family and we
we could see this in the in the 10k
fraction but also in the ev fraction
and i'm going to leave it at that so
that i can just just briefly touch on
one other technology that we've been
using and so i mentioned earlier that we
had found some new markers
in evs in the brain that we'd like to
follow up in the periphery
so markers that we could use to pull out
microglial
or macrophage-specific evs markers that
we could use to pull out neuronal evs
that might not be
um might not have been studied before so
we're using this uh this technology
that's called single particle
interferometric reflectance imaging
sensing um and you can see the chip here
so this is a silicon dioxide coated chip
onto which antibodies or you could use
other affinity reagents
to be printed and so each of these
little dots of antibodies or lawns of
antibodies
will then capture a particular particle
type so
um so we we used we used several capture
antibodies in the chip that i'm showing
you here
um including several general ev markers
and then also several
several markers that we expect to be on
neurons
after the particle is captured onto that
antibody lawn
we can do an interferometric based
imaging
and this interferometric imaging will
give us the the
the diameter of the particle and then
also
we can we can count how many particles
have been captured by each of the
affinity reagents
um another another modality with this
with this
instrumentation is that we can then go
in with up to three fluorescently
labeled antibodies
um and assess the degree of signal the
positivity that might come from
any of those three on the specifically
captured particles so this is a true
single particle analysis technology
that lets us say antibody a
is capturing this particle and then we
also see these other markers on the
surface
and i think what was um what was very
revealing to us is that we found that
there was
there was actually not a lot of l1 cam
that we could detect on the surface of
the beat
of the brain-derived db's now that
doesn't mean that l1 cam is not there it
certainly is
but there might be other neuronal
markers that could be even better than
l1 cam
at allowing us to capture those neuron
derived dbs in the periphery
and this is also consistent with some
some bulk measurements that we've done
using some of these same samples using
uh for example the mesoscale
multiplexed protein assay
so we have we do have some some other
markers that
have been have been found to be
associated with the apoe genotypes i'm
not going to talk about them right now
but we are we're pursuing what we've
just found here and i'm just gonna
just a few conclusions before we get to
um to the to the questions but
we were able to obtain uh brain derived
dbs that we believe are
acceptable purity um using this size
exclusion chromatography
um method and this is because it's
partly
partially automatable the sec portion of
it anyway
we can process a lot more samples this
way we do want to stress that factors
including
postmortem interval should be taken into
account and reported too in any study of
of any tissue derived dbs
but especially in the brain we were able
to see that our separation protocol did
yield
results that were consistent with the
pure ev population
and we were able to identify some
markers that may be
as good as or better than the field
standards right now
in identifying cell specific um evs in
in
outside of the outside of the brain so
so you know i mean it's interesting to
look in the brain but
but the brain was just the source that's
where we start we want to understand
what's there
and then look for it elsewhere um so we
have some ongoing collaborations
um to to understand a little bit more
about these apoe genotypes that maybe
may only have subtle effects on on on
ebs in their cargo but
but we we have some evidence that
they're there and then of course we use
we also use cell culture models to try
to understand
the interactions between the different
cells in the brain so i will conclude my
talk by i'm just putting a little plug
in for the international society for
extracellular vesicles i talked about
their standardization efforts
um i've been serving as the the chair
for science and meetings for the society
for several years
and if you have interest in learning
more about eb's or if you would like to
just to host a workshop maybe on a
particular eb topic
please get in contact with me and we
also have
a subcommittee it's called the rigor and
standardization subcommittee where we
have multiple task forces that have been
formed so
this is also an opportunity for members
of the community to say you know what i
don't
i don't see anything about brain derived
evs i'd like to start a task force on
that
um and there's an opportunity on the
isiv
webpage to get involved in that way so
thank you again
uh for inviting me to speak here and i'm
happy to take any questions that um that
you might have
and thank you dr whitware for that
informative presentation
we will now start the q a portion of the
webinar
if you have any questions you want to
ask please do so now
just click on that ask a question box
located on the far
left of your screen so let's get started
we already have
some incoming questions from our
audience members
dr whitwork are blood isolated bevs
emerging as a novel player in the study
of
alzheimer's disease and are bevs
considered as a blood-based
biomarker of alzheimer's so
the answer to that is yes absolutely and
i think there are many
academic labs but then also many
companies that are working on this so
um so if if if there's something to be
found i think it will be in the next in
the next few years
um if it hasn't been already i think
that
you know we have this question about
specificity
so there are very few molecular markers
that are truly specific to any one cell
type
and that's a biological reality that we
have to deal with
[Music]
and
oops it looks like he accidentally just
stepped out of
the studio and we're gonna try to get
him back
in here i apologize to the audience
members
and hopefully he will be right back in
sometimes we have these audio glitches
and so we'll try to figure out what is
happening
oh please
i do apologize it was great
he's got this wonderful calm voice huh
so i'm sure he'll be right back in
everyone's small we get bounced so i do
apologize
and i do want to remind you that if you
have any questions you want to ask
this is a good time to go ahead and
enter them into
our q a box you can find that up at the
left hand corner
looks like already many of you have
figured that out
so go ahead and add that in there
and i'll give him another minute and
hopefully he will come right back in
here
if you haven't had a chance make sure
you go to labrets.com and check out some
of the other conferences that are
um going to be available this month we
have so many
amazing conferences that are being um
held here on the lab route site it's a
great site
social media for all doctors researchers
anyone in the medical field
so it's important for you to take
advantage of that
opportunity and it looks like he is back
in we just need
him to connect let me just um connect
him
you must
i'm sure he's going to get right in here
um
so yeah take a take a good look at the
different conferences that are out there
um you know lab roots does connect
um you know people in the medical field
with
all kinds of wonderful conferences so
you can
you can register and um you know join
labyrinths so that way you can get
updates and find out about other things
that are happening okay
it says this is the presenter
yes
all right it looks like he'll be in here
you should
be right back oh there he is oh yes
yeah it seems that the connection cut up
i mean
no worries and i we we have such a great
audience that
all of them remained here so okay well
thank you very much
i don't know did my adventure come
through
uh i'm sorry the the so the uh the
the question about the novel players in
alzheimer's disease did did were they
were people able to hear that one or
should i go back to it yes we heard that
and then the second part of that one is
that is it difficult to distinguish
among
ev types simply on the basis of protein
markers
or size alone and again before you
answer that i just want to thank our
audience for being patient
and staying with us and they've already
started asking additional questions so
we appreciate that
welcome back dr it let's go for it
all right so size no i don't think that
there is
anything that we can do that will well i
i
i shouldn't i shouldn't close the door
completely on that i mean i mentioned
the large oncosomes
when you see a very large uv there's
only a certain number of cell types that
it could even give rise to that
um but i think in when we're talking
about healthy cells
um or reasonably healthy cells i i don't
expect that we're going to be able to
say where a particle came from just by
its size
and that's why we need to have these
molecular signatures and ideally you
know ideally
even more than one and so moving towards
a more single particle kind of analysis
is important so something that i often
say and i think
terry says this too is you know we're
kind of where
immunology was in the 1970s with evs
where um you know it was possible to
look at some markers on the surface of
an immune cell back then but it was only
with the development of multi-parametric
flow cytometry
um that we could really understand the
different subtypes of immune cells
and in the same way i think that we need
to be able to do that now for ebs
because it's much harder because there's
so much less surface area
but to the extent that we can if we can
understand phenotypes
um that will allow us to understand what
cell is the
has the the eb come from and then also
maybe some characteristics
some some something about the health of
that cell
thank you so much and what is the most
common
eevee separation technique and what are
considered the most broadly applied
characterization methods besides
single particle tracking well that's a
that's a great question
and it um i can refer you to a
publication that just came
from isev and it was published in the
mdpi journal called
cells um so the first author is royo
r-o-y-o
and so we did a survey of the isib
community
and what we found was that um ultra
centrifugation is still
most widely employed method for eb
separation
now this i think every every separation
technology has
its advantages and disadvantages the
disadvantage of ultra centrifugation is
that it doesn't
doesn't result in a really highly pure
product
um and can also result in damage to the
extra specifically so depending on what
you want to do with them
if you want to do functional studies
molecular characterization
uh it might not be the best method but
there have been numerous
um you know numerous advances in the
past in the past
decade i mean there's been a lot of
changes so what we're seeing is that
there's a lot more
size exclusion chromatography being
applied of course a very old technique
but now being applied to evs
and other other types of chromatography
you know so where you can just use a
matrix
um an affinity matrix a sizing matrix um
a combination of
of different matrices to achieve a very
gentle separation so i i see that um you
know
matrix based you know binding dilute
chromatography or
or traditional chromatography would be
the kind of um
a kind of way that you can get your evs
um
in a reasonably pure fashion without
without uh harming them and
as for characterization methods uh
so i think that protein protein-based
characterisation is still
at the top so western blotting or
proteomics whatever it is that you're
doing to
understand what proteins are there but
then
you mentioned single particle tracking
you also like nanoparticle tracking
analysis or resistive pulse sensing to
understand numbers and
sizes um but you know
we recently had a workshop on on imaging
of ebs and i think seeing
seeing is believing is the old adage um
and so electron microscopy is is a
widely used method cryoelectron
microscopy now can really show you a lot
of details about individual evs
um and then even you know super
resolution microscopy
has has has come into the arena fairly
recently and is is really helping us to
make strides in our understanding of ev
biology
come on i should mention
thank you so much for your presentation
today i want to just tell you that
your audience many of them wrote in and
said this was an incredible presentation
we don't have time to answer any more
questions today but i do want to thank
you for your time and for your important
research and i want to thank
our audience for joining us today and
for their interesting questions
and any questions we didn't have time
today please know that they
can be submitted during all the way
through the on-demand period and will be
addressed by our speaker via email
of the contact information provided at
the time of registration
and this webcast can be viewed on demand
for six months
until march of 2021 labyrinths will
alert you via email
when it's available for replay we
encourage you to share that email with
your colleagues who may have missed
today's
live event until next time take care
stay healthy
thank you again dr whitmer thank you